All right, today we're talking
about something you've
definitely seen, but maybe never
had a name for.
It's this hidden process, a
machine really, that takes
dangerous people and ideas and
turns them into, well, harmless
products.
We're calling it deburring
radicals.
So let's just get right to it
with the central puzzle here.
You've seen it a million times,
right?
How does a revolutionary, I
mean, someone who wanted to burn
the whole system to the ground,
end up as a fashion statement on
a T-shirt?
And, you know, to really get at
that question, we have to start
with the ultimate example, the
absolute poster child for
revolution on a T-shirt.
OK, so this is the core of it.
The paradox is just massive.
On one hand, you've got the
icon, right?
Che Guevara.
He's the symbol of rebellion you
see on every college dorm wall.
But then you have the man, a
totally ruthless guerrilla
commander, an uncompromising
Marxist who, let's be clear,
personally executed people he
saw as traitors.
These two versions, they're not
even in the same universe.
So how in the world do you get
from one to the other?
Well, it doesn't happen by
accident.
There's this incredibly powerful
cultural process at work.
Think of it as a kind of
machine.
We're going to call it the
deburring machine.
So deburring, what does that
even mean?
Well, picture a piece of freshly
cut metal.
It's got all these sharp,
jagged, dangerous edges.
You know, burrs.
Deburring is the process of
sanding all those sharp edges
down, smoothing them out until
what was once a weapon is, well,
it's just a polished, harmless
object you can hold in your
hand.
And that's exactly what happens
to ideas.
You neutralize the danger until
it's safe enough to put on a
shelf and sell.
And you know, this whole thing
follows a pretty predictable
playbook.
It's like a four step process.
Step 1A, radical idea pops up
and it absolutely terrifies the
establishment.
Step 2, the leader of that idea
is neutralized.
Often that means they're killed.
Then comes the really clever
part.
Step three, their image gets
completely disconnected from
their actual dangerous ideas.
And finally, step four, that
clean, safe image gets polished,
rebranded, and sold to the
masses.
The threat is totally gone, but
the brand, the brand is more
popular than ever.
OK, so let's put this deburring
machine to the test, and we're
going to start with a case study
of someone we all think we know
inside and out.
Let's look at the dreamer versus
the radical.
So when you think of Martin
Luther King Junior, what's the
first thing that comes to mind?
For most of us, it's the I Have
a Dream speech, right?
The version we celebrate every
January is the prophet of a
color blind America, a peaceful
visionary.
It's the safe, inspirational
version we all learned about in
history class.
But here's the thing.
That picture is so incomplete,
it's almost a different person.
The gap between the mascot and
the man is just staggering.
The mascot is safe.
The man especially.
Towards the end of his life, he
was a fierce critic of American
capitalism and militarism.
He was organizing a poor
people's campaign.
He was considered so dangerous
by the establishment that the
FBI was spying on him, trying to
slander him.
That's not the same guy.
I mean, just listen to this.
In 1967, talking about the
Vietnam War, he said, and I'm
quoting directly, the United
States is the greatest purveyor
of violence in the world today.
Wow, just let that sink in.
That is not the man from the
inspirational posters, is it?
All those sharp, uncomfortable
edges of his message, they've
been totally sanded away.
And look, it wasn't just King.
Think about Malcolm X.
His phrase, by any means
necessary, was one of the
sharpest, most radical
statements in American politics.
But over time, what's happened?
That edge has been softened.
He's become this general symbol
of empowerment, which is true,
but the most revolutionary and
for many terrifying parts of his
philosophy often get
conveniently left out.
OK, so with all that in mind,
let's circle back to our guy on
the T-shirt.
Let's look at Che again, but
this time through our new
deburring lens.
The mascot versus the Marxist.
Let's just ask a simple
question.
The real Che Guevara, the
hardcore anti capitalist
revolutionary.
How many shopping malls do you
think he would have been cool
with selling his face on a
T-shirt?
Yeah, the answer is a big fat 0.
And that's really the whole
trick, isn't it?
The Che on the T-shirt is a
ghost.
He's been completely cut off
from the actual man and what he
did.
He's just a generic symbol for
rebellion, a fashion statement.
The actual dangerous
revolutionary.
He's gone.
All that's left is the safe,
sellable mascot.
Now you might think this is just
a modern political thing, but
this deburring process is
ancient.
It goes back centuries.
Let's wind the clock back and
look at a different kind of
battle.
The Saint versus the
revolutionary.
OK, think of Francis of Assisi.
We picture the gentle guy with
birds on his shoulder, right?
The little statue you put in
your garden.
That's the de bird version.
The real Francis was a radical.
He founded an order based on
absolute hardcore poverty.
He called out all wealth as a
poison.
His movement was so extreme, so
revolutionary, it sent shock
waves of terror through the
church establishment.
And if you want to see the
ultimate example of this, some
argue, you just have to look at
Jesus.
I mean, think about it.
The man who physically flipped
tables and whipped money lenders
out of the temple.
The preacher whose message was
about a new Kingdom that would
completely overturn the existing
powers.
The guy who was seen as such a
massive political threat that
the Roman Empire publicly
executed him.
That guy gets transformed into a
sweet, harmless baby in a
Manger.
The most dangerous person
imaginable becomes the coziest
story we tell at Christmas.
So this isn't just ancient
history.
This machine is running right
now all around us, and you
always know when the process is
complete because it always ends
in the same place when the
radical idea finally becomes a
product you can buy.
For instance, you take radical
feminism, a movement demanding A
fundamental tear down and
rebuilding of society, and what
does it become?
Girl boss mugs and T-shirts.
See, the system didn't crush it,
it ate it.
Or what about punk rock?
A whole culture built on anti
corporate, anti establishment
rage.
And today it's a fashion
aesthetic you can buy at a shop
in the mall.
Mall punk, the ultimate
contradiction.
And one more, the hippie
counterculture which was all
about rejecting materialism and
consumer society.
Where do you find it now?
Neatly folded in the tie dye
section at Target.
The irony is just, it's perfect,
isn't it?
So you see the strategy now,
right?
It's genius in a way.
The system doesn't have to crush
its enemies.
That's messy.
It's much smarter to just eat
them, absorb them, digest them,
and then sell a safe, neatly
packaged version of them right
back to the people who might
have once been inspired by the
real thing.
And what's the end result of all
this?
The dangerous revolutionary, The
person who was on fire with a
world changing idea.
They're just gone, erased.
And what's left in their place?
A kind of Santa Claus.
Jolly, safe, completely non
threatening and perfect for
selling products during the
holidays.
Look, once you learn to spot
this pattern, you will not be
able to Unsee it.
You'll see it happening
everywhere.
So the question I want to leave
you with isn't about Che or MLK,
it's about right now.
Take a look around who is being
devilorized as we speak.